au 27 février la france a administré 4,5
millions de doses de vaccin selon les
statistiques du site the world in data
elle se situe juste derrière le champion
de l'union européenne l'allemagne avec
5,9 millions de doses injectées mais en
fin de compte cela représente seulement
un peu plus de 6% de la population
un pourcentage qui fait dégringoler
l'hexagone dans le classement des
leaders de la vaccination
la france est loin très loin même de la
première marche du podium trusté par
israël 93 5 % des israéliens ont reçu au
moins une première dose de vaccin anti
qu'ovide 19 au 28 février
elle est aussi derrière des pays comme
les etats-unis avec 22 25% le maroc avec
9 75% ou encore les émirats arabes unis
avec 60,81 7% au sein de l'union
européenne la france aussi accusent un
retard
le pays se retrouve derrière la pologne
la roumanie ou encore l'espagne emmanuel
macron s'était pourtant engagé à ce que
l'ensemble de la population adulte du
moins ceux qui le souhaitent puissent
être vaccinées d'ici à la fin ou 2021
malgré ce retard en france le
coordinateur de la stratégie vaccinale
contre le coc vite 19
alain fischer s'est montré plutôt
optimiste quant à l'évolution de la
vaccination
le problème principal est de s'assurer
que les livraisons arrivent en temps et
en heure
le programme potentiel des livraisons va
croissant de façon très nette en mars et
encore plus en avril
mieux qu'en février s'il n'y a pas de
mauvaise surprise dans les livraisons
il y a potentiellement de quoi vacciner
l'ensemble de la population adulte au
cours de l'été sauf qu'au rythme actuel
et en partant du principe que tous les
adultes français désirent recevoir le
vaccin
il faudrait attendre juillet 2
23 pour que ces 52 millions de français
soit vaccinée c'est en tout cas ce
qu'estime le site qu'ovide tracker
autant dire qu'il va falloir mettre les
bouchées doubles pour tenir la promesse
présidentielle